for a second one well let's do it
just when I finish the first one I
really hope there would be a [ __ ]
other one so a few of you brothers
wanted me to play the other one okay a
lot of your brothers wanted me to play
the other one we're gonna [ __ ] finish
it and then we get never gonna shed
again where does the general keep his
armies well this sure as hell is in
[ __ ] barracks in the bin up is up his
sleeves Oh army which of the following
do you need to build a green house paint
yeah don't get ahead of yourself pants
which is the largest okay so you think
oh they're all chocolate bars except
earth
what is this and can a marry captain
Frank says press ooh well I say [ __ ]
press D twice okay press E what how many
sentences in this centre what oh how
many letters in this engine okay so I
counted 27 28
so those [ __ ] think that you're
gonna choose 28 or 29 six six is Tosh
[ __ ] it's eight yes
use the right key the right key now shut
up
that is one sexy F key hole this is a
trick question isn't it it looks at this
one [ __ ] you which which one is it I
can't skip karat Emily
why is his eyebrows upside down the
right key right click that is the
dumbest [ __ ] [ __ ] I have ever [ __ ]
heard it's supposed to press your
[ __ ] keyboard where does the Great
Wall of China start ten letters in it
what evolved [ __ ] skip what happens if
you pick up a penguin it pecks your face
up so god damn it how do I know
oh nice
hey what happens if you pick up a
penguin up nothing
what the [ __ ] what what what don't touch
the blue and don't try to cheat
don't drop the key don't drop the key
don't drop your key this is gonna be fun
[Applause]
answer this question upside down
cucumber
okay now for [ __ ] sake what fine
what what do Germans water the gardens
with urine come on how might how am I
supposed to know what a German is what
are their gardens with ears I'm I'm fine
Germans I don't know what you do okay
leather leather horse end okay nice what
happens if I click these I can move them
what a what holy [ __ ] click the question
number twice what is good baby don't
Jesus that now for [ __ ] sake a large
man with really nice beard what dog
backward what is the name of the
impossible quiz cat oh yeah that [ __ ]
[ __ ] you bros remember well at corporal
arse
what is the name of the impossible quiz
cat Glenn and for [ __ ] sake restive
[ __ ] Chris Brown Garrett funny
Oh what the [ __ ] what is the
spider-man's favorite food horse my
watch spider-man fly sandwiches
Horace fly sandwiches what is this bomb
blaster purple bastard hue stopper one
of those what the [ __ ]
purple Basten pew summer yes
all right drive tick off for [ __ ] sake
that is uh
why oh you're welcome how many quits is
this the very first impossible quiz I
wonder in town 46 million pretty sure I
[ __ ] and finish the other one pretty
[ __ ] you sure it had [ __ ] hundred
and ten thirty what what dead isn't even
know what is the candy floss made Anna
bluff [ __ ] it's not fluff it's pink
cards win Oh
which of the following can be found
under the sea space when is a door not a
door when it's a pig I'm also [ __ ]
when it's knob when it's ajar Oh a jar a
flock of seagulls approaching what do
you do kick them through a window for
[ __ ] sake follow me what I don't
understand there's no logic behind this
punched her tiny kidney you run you run
so far away fara de ok so you don't far
to them you don't kick them but you do
punch their tiny kidneys
Iran I guess [ __ ] Priss press for [ __ ]
sake press one
where's the one there it is
what where's the [ __ ] one you piece
of [ __ ] what is this that is spot
this is sparta hahahaha I don't trust
that why is happening to me
how many holes in a blow - oh for [ __ ]
sake
one three decks in the [ __ ] what will
you want from a we're not gonna give up
first off what the [ __ ] is a Rolo how
many holes do they have I would say they
have zero [ __ ] holes but what do I
know about life how many holes in a row
low zero
you [ __ ] you [ __ ] [ __ ] how do you
get a two whales in a car you're an
idiot
drive down the m4 that's okay let's
think about this you think about this to
get to Wales in a car you need to Wow
Wales is spelled into MP with two things
like wow and less Wow
means when you're scared and less is a
way to define in Mexican Spanish so wow
this is like what Spanish and and
everyone knows that if you are a Spanish
[ __ ] you take one in the front and then
one in the background check how the [ __ ]
I don't know you don't you're an idiot
well drive down the [ __ ] gun what the
answer looks like a pair of bare arses
what Britney Spears forehead a combine
dirty boy the answer looks like a pair
of bare arses walnuts no no way what
Baroness yeah presidents to kill
yourself before the bomb does no [ __ ]
you I'm not gonna do that
I guess I [ __ ] [ __ ] I don't know why
how do you play darts with a baby
wearing a bib aim for the face yes of
course why why do them did the Mexican
throw his wife of a cliff poncho
sombrero tequila to kill her yeah what I
didn't mean but I did get to a god damn
it I gotta skip that one
mash Oh God where its face oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] put the mouse here oh
god what the [ __ ] off for [ __ ] sake
you [ __ ] [ __ ] aah
oh thank god which impossible quiz can
help you see hidden meanings to chat to
can know it's to con to I don't even
know why it's this one right what Pig
buster No
what am I doing with my life what is
this [ __ ] okay
[Applause]
what oh oh yes all your base are belong
to us you are on the way to destruction
how are you gentlemen what what what you
saying that's it Old MacDonald had a
farm
oh my darling had a farm back you
require one elephant what do I draw it
or how how the [ __ ] lies
what what what
it's [ __ ] game I don't even
understand virus Orion's belt around
Orion's waist what is this
public transport meteor garlic God why
did you do this I really look out there
bank near a supermarket street corners
use be a boy yes Frank says press Delete
lots of time go [ __ ] snort some coke
and explore your sexuality how about
that Frank how many times do you
one-minute a cap that is definitely a
lots of time I do you wanted me to press
here
why oh god it's a dog again what do you
want dog badly no you're not by tadam
you look good complete the episode how
how how what is happening to that [ __ ]
ah come on I'm gonna fail I'm gonna fail
I'm gonna fail
yes shut up shut the [ __ ] up
oh [ __ ] five animalistic part in a yacht
race around the world which came last
which kick what camel ass Welker
goddamnit you shake it right
oh that is one ugly ass [ __ ] click
where the arrows pointing what's a
crumpet sir what crumpets half a [ __ ]
I refuse
where's they're manageable effect ballet
man Oh
[Laughter]
sharra what what did watching what how
or do you get Pikachu on the bus for
free iPod hammer to the face piss on his
shins poke em on poke em on got nothi
said again what what are you oh ouch
vent face oh Lola micropenis how many
letters in the answer 1 2 3 4 5 6
[ __ ] you yes ok I knew that I'm sharing
sorry
oh no there's a comment alright just
dodge all the [ __ ] which what am I
supposed to take hey my what I press
space in that what this [ __ ] [ __ ]
how do you make that varnish disappear
balance cream you make varnish oh you do
not pull oh come on this is dumb I I
shove it up yes
oh god what I do I do why
what do I do now I'm supposed to like
lick it he's gonna come Oh God oh [ __ ]
now
Oh God oops why did the chicken cross
the road okay so let's let's think here
for a second chicken cross what looks
like a chicken cross a butthole Lord in
Portuguese is actually backwards for
battle in in Chinese so it's not Lord
the other one starts with the because
and this one starts with T because mr. t
wants to go to the other side because
he's an idiot because he want to take a
dump
Lord that which cheese is made backwards
Arab made funny
what is the seventeenth letter of the
alphabet square of onion there's only 11
letters in alphabet let's see
spot the difference [ __ ] what is a cow's
favorite beverage Stella Artois Stella
backwards is a lots
which is Japanese for blood so it has to
be water blood
what what is going on I'm not gonna do
that
Oh oh god oh god oh god okay [ __ ] you
did all me feet bunny jab that cute get
up it's gone
all right price I'm gonna have to end it
here I think we did pretty well I'm
actually pretty proud of myself if you
want part to leave it like I really
appreciate it hits the sky recovered
with today ICU breaths in the next one
Salem love you [ __ ] is that guy gonna do
with that it's so beautiful